rassemblement en cours devant le
ministère de la santé pour le maintien
des hôpitaux bichat et beaujon notre
reporter kata technique et sur place
tian bonjour les hôpitaux bichat et
beaujon sont menacés de fermeture
oui c'est pour cela qu un rassemblement
a été organisé aujourd'hui à l'appel des
syndicats fo et cgt de l'assistance
publique et du collectif inter urgences
alors il regroupe des personnels
hospitaliers médicaux et non médicaux
des services de soins des services
techniques médico technique est l'objet
c'est de dire non à ce projet de
fermeture de ces deux hôpitaux
il demande à olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé
l'arrêt de ce projet de fermeture le
maintien des services de proximité des
services d'excellence la rénovation de
ces hôpitaux et bien sûr le maintien de
tous les postes de travail alors un
cortège est parti tout à l'heure de
l'hôpital beaujon il arrive vous allez
pas vous le montrer les dents la rue il
en train de rejoindre cet endroit proche
du ministère de la santé et donc pour
parler de ces problématiques
je suis actuellement avec christophe
prudhomme délégué national cgt est
médecin à l'assistance publique
alors bonjour christophe prudhomme merci
de nous répondre
dites-nous aujourd'hui pourquoi ces
décisions de fermeture de bichat et
beaujon bien écoutez c'est ce sont les
programmes que le gouvernement a mis en
place ce gouvernement et les précédents
de restructuration de l'hôpital avec des
fermetures massives de lit nous avons
fermé cent mille lits en 25 ans en
france c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle l'hôpital public a été en
grande difficulté pour prendre en charge
les malades atteints de l'aco vide donc
il faut arrêter ces fermetures de lits
il faut même en rouvrir dans un certain
nombre d'endroits
sauf que aujourd'hui et bien les
programmes de restructuration de
fermetures de lits sont toujours à
l'ordre du jour c'est la raison de notre
colère et notre manifestation
aujourd'hui si je comprends bien ce
n'est pas uniquement pour un bichon
besoin de vous
lisez votre appel est plus large
finalement l'appel est plus large
puisque rien qu'en ile de france nous
avons bichat et beaujon avec moins 350
lits l'hôpital jean verdier en
seine-saint-denis qui doit fermer
l'hôpital de garches dans le 92
l'hôpital de beaumont sur oise qui
menaçaient les hôpitaux d'orsay juvisy
longjumeau vous voyez il faut qu'on
arrête ces fermetures de lits puisque je
suis médecin urgentiste et depuis 2003
depuis la canicule
nous manquons lui nous manque on le dit
et on poursuit les restructurations pour
des opérations financières vous savez
c'est toujours le même thème
il faut faire des économies sur le
budget de la sécurité sociale
sauf que si nous avions eu plus de lits
plus de lits pour gérer ses différentes
vagues de l'aco vide qui aurait
peut-être eu moins de morts noyés parce
que non seulement vous avez eu des
difficultés pour prendre en charge ce
mal-être coville mais nous avons laissé
tomber tous les autres malades
et ça les répercussions sur les
infarctus sur les avc sur les cancers
donc l'hôpital n'a pas été en capacité
de gérer cette crise qui n'avait rien
finalement de catastrophique on a eu un
nombre de mâles important mais passe
voyez c'était pas d'aider des centaines
de malades qui arrivait dans chaque
hôpital chaque jour donc il faut que le
gouvernement nous écoute
alors ce qui nous rend plutôt optimiste
c'est que en province nous avons réussi
à débloquer les situations comme à
nantes ou la reconstruction du chu
finalement va se faire sans les
fermetures de lits qui était prévu il
était prévu à la fermeture 292 lits et
c'est annulé donc si ça annule un nom
qu'il faut l'annuler sur paris paris
c'est une première métropoles mondiales
et donc il faut que paris soit dotée
d'un système hospitalier qui lui
permettent de répondre aux besoins de sa
population et les touristes qui vont
revenir voilà très rapidement vous avez
eu le sentiment de ne pas être assez
entendu et que le ségur n'ont écouté le
ségur c'est très en-deça de ce qu'on
souhaitait mais vous savez les le single
se résume à quoi à une augmentation de
183 euros et encore pas pour tout le
monde puisqu'il ya eu des manifestations
régulières pour ce qu'on appelle les
exclus du ségur ont d'une part ça ne
fait que rattraper la perte de pouvoir
d'achat depuis dix ans puisque les
salaires étaient bloquées mais ne va
rien sur les lits et rien sur les
personnels
une des raisons pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui des listes ont fermé des
lits qui devraient tous vers son père
mais c'est que nous manquons de
personnel alors que nous manquons de
personnel dans mon établissement que
l'assistance milk hôpitaux de paris le
directeur général martin hirsch refuse
l'entrée à l'école d'infirmière pour 120
aide soignante qu'on réussit le concours
parce qu il
apa le financement il n'a pas l'argent à
un moment donné qu'on n'est pas l'argent
pour former 120 personnes à paris enfin
qu'on n'est pas l'argent pour former des
professionnels de santé aujourd'hui
alors que l'activité redémarre ce que je
viens de lire dans le journal ce matin
que les entreprises du cac 40 avaient
des bénéfices qui ré augmentait il a
écouté de l'argent il y en a il faut le
prendre au bon endroit sûr merci
beaucoup à christophe prudhomme et nous
suivons donc ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée juste à
l'instant du collectif qui faisait du
cortège qui venait de l'hôpital beaujon
nous suivons la situation ici près du
ministère de la santé
et on vous retrouvera un kata technique
tout au long de cette journée merci